哇 怎麼辦 台灣股市今天又殺尾盤了
而且我今天要告訴你
沒有三大東西
台股今天殺尾盤收跌379點 為什麼
第二個 我要再告訴你
明天台股會放颱風架嗎
AI直接告訴你 不會放的
我要讓你知道 AI
可以做很多事情
真的嗎
傳統的一個區域
傳統模式 那種區域模式
告訴你明天要放颱風架
有可能甚至於侵襲台灣
可是AI告訴你
可能不會清醒台灣
怎麼會這樣子
真好玩
什麼都可以跟AI承擔關係
第三個
7月52000
還有機會嗎
這些獨家的預告
我今天三大重點
我一次要跟你說得清楚
為什麼台灣股市今天尾盤收跌
一切一切
這次預告前面
台股今天只不過是輕輕反彈一下
而投資長的股票
就有三檔噴漲停
投資長的好戲登場精彩
這檔股票
股價直接跳空噴出
連續兩天都噴漲停
再創歷史新高
還有環球金和南亞科
今天也都噴上漲停啦
台股今天的表現看起來還不錯
但是台股今天盤中又破底
韓股今天台中又破底
投資長也早就預告
如果台股強勢下去
那韓股就不能再繼續跌
否則台股遲早會受影響
投資朋友們也都很好奇
明天下午南亞科的法說會結束後
是否可以繼續加碼南亞科呢
想知道更多股市消息嗎
你手上還沒有標股嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
國哲榮投資長
投資長好
莉莉 各位投資長大家好
你今天有點緊張
有一點
有一點點
好啦 沒有關係
所以每天錄影比較好
來啦 姐姐已經跟你先預告了啦
我認為明天不會放台灣假啦
真的嗎
我覺得不會
除非那個蔣娃安市長
那個政治考量
不然應該不會
這個也有部分可能
姐姐有私心嗎
因為姐姐就愛工作
我不知道
大家可以講為什麼
好啦
那可是今天為什麼殺尾盤
奇怪韓國股市今天也沒到殺尾盤
為什麼台灣股市現在殺尾盤
你知道為什麼今天殺尾盤嗎
為什麼呢
很簡單吧
因為大家怕明天放假啦
是這樣子喔
多少會有怕啊
為什麼 你去想看看
如果你想到明年
台灣股市搖搖欲墜
再一根就可能跌破月線
這次跌破季線
你會緊張會不會
有一點
會緊張啊
你看這邊是
這月線剛好這邊
月線現在失手了有沒有看到
好 再一根可能就要攻擊季線了
韓國股市季線這邊都跌破了
再一根你就直接怎麼辦
這一個景線跌破了
甚至連這個景線也會跌破
所以先賣再說
可是他們不知道 AI告訴你
明天不會放假
所以要不要投資 AI 股
我先跟大家講啦
我覺得蠻好玩的
我少數看到前幾天
有差這麼多的
我先講大家
有關係台灣股市
又有關係 AI 股的
又有關係什麼
那個颱風價的事情
好不好一起講好不好
來
來我們來看一下
這大概12點多的一個模式
傳統模式有沒有看到
哇塞
從那邊走過去
看起來不會登錄的啦
你不會登陸台灣
可是不會登陸台灣不是比較好喔
因為不會登陸台灣喔
台灣真的是你知道
護國什麼
護國神山啊
是
除了那個
除了什麼
護國神山
大家講台積電嘛
不是 是中央山脈
除了台積電外有中央山脈
經過中央山脈
任何颱風不論強台
都會被它一刀斬斃
會被它切成一半
可是它剛好沒有經過
怎麼樣
沒有經過中央山脈
所以這種如果繞過去的話
對北台灣反而最危險
因為它強風暴雨
它的中心颱風也不會受損失
這兩件事情很恐怖的
是
所以傳統模式這樣子告訴你說
這樣不會
這樣子雖然不會登陸台灣
但對北台灣來講
怎麼辦
我好像氣象主播
對北台灣來講
反而受傷最嚴重
聽說南部多少會有雨
但沒有緊接著西南氣流
不要再說了
再說我真的約一下
人力雨像那些
你們分譯是怎麼都懂
你要談醫學 談什麼都要懂
真的
分譯是不好單啦
來
來看下去
這邊是傳統模式
好
這已經是明天要
明天已經是要陸上海
陸上颱風
剛公佈海上颱風
海上警報嘛對不對
明天要發佈陸上警報了
結果你今天還在傳統模式這個東西啦
你看這樣走對不對
這樣走沒錯吧
是
這樣走對不對
這台灣對不對
對
AI模式有沒有看
有經過台灣嗎
沒有耶
到現在還沒有經過啦
太空了吧
這差很多耶
真的喔
這邊我跟妳講
這邊就是稍微風而已啊
台灣就明天會下雨
但是那個風妳可以接受
瞬間爆大風而已啊
好不好
可能不會到時期正風然後要放假
AI模式這樣子啦
明天我深夜可能就會
就會稍微登陸了
這樣子啦
一個是這樣子啦
一個這樣子一個這樣子
差點來桌
觀眾朋友你們投什麼模式
我們剛順便投票一下好不好
投票
投票妳覺得會是
颱風路徑是AI模式
請四條做一下
一個颱風路徑是傳統模式
就是以前就是一般人的
我們人工在算的
是
登入二晚溪啊遇到哪邊啊
OK 傳統模式告訴你往這邊
遇到這邊哪邊有什麼氣流影響啊
高氣壓低氣壓影響
傳統模式走這邊
經過台灣善滅
那個相對的一些颱風半徑啊
會清洗北台灣
AI模式完全摸不到邊際啊
慘的是什麼
這禮拜可能要去什麼
沖繩的人會稍微危險一點點
沖繩在這邊嗎
還好還好
重點是沖繩的人比較危險一點點
AI模式台灣有驚無險
大家覺得是AI模式還是什麼
傳統模式
大家猜一下
基本上不是哪個模式喔
基本上放假機率都很低啦
因為明天這個時候
兩點的時候
還很遠啦好不好
兩點的時候還很遠
好不好 OK嗎
所以他投票一下
你覺得是AI模式會
傳統模式會那個
輕騎台灣
不一定登錄啦 輕騎台灣
然後AI模式不輕騎台灣
大家覺得是哪一種
好不好
當然你一定有多少主觀意見啦
有些人就哎呀我想要
禮拜六我不想要送啦
或怎麼樣啊
或禮拜六五號Uber啊
你看明天喔 你們看到
我有吶吧在這邊
這個這樣開始每分每秒
你看明天
兩點還在這邊
有沒有看到
感覺我們是走什麼
走傳統模式的
你聽懂嗎
就是我們台灣
那個台灣政府氣象局
是走傳統模式
你看起來這邊
會不會
明天兩點這個時候
對記得我們明天那個
公司有慶公宴
是
今年營收不錯啦
這個摩托酷工業界最大的
員工旅遊也是怎麼樣
也是最好的
我們是最好的
最好的
我們今天這種公司把
商務艙 頭等艙 豪金艙全部都包下來了
然後是新宇最高級的飛機
那叫什麼啊
你記不記得
我記得
350個是
好 它350
如果有飛機迷就知道了
車遠的啦
為什麼要講這個東西
為什麼那個問題
慶功宴
慶功宴 對慶功宴
明天慶功宴
所以我們明天1點半錄影
明天1點半錄影好不好
我們什麼沒有福利最多好不好
來
明天1點半慶功宴好不好
為什麼福利好
福利好才有標股啊
很多人說怎麼那麼多標股
廢話
我們就福利好
大家很認真選標股啊
你懂不懂
懂
福利好啊
Lily也是因為福利好才來的
所以
頭長我一開始不知道頭顧做什麼
沒錯
來才知道
看薪水高就來了
就是這麼簡單
來
兩點
所以明天一點半我就要錄影了
好不好
不好意思
我們要慶功一下早點
趕快找他們吃一吃
趕快早點走
因為明天還好
明天應該不會犯颱風假
好不好
OK
這跟大家講
我覺得不論是傳統模式
還是AI模式
但是我說實話
如果就AI
就那個東西的話
就什麼東西
就氣下來講話
我真的不算專業
可是我覺得不論是傳統模式
還是AI模式
基本上
記得投票
基本上都不會什麼
明天都不會犯假
除非講話
有特殊的想法
好不好
来
那我们来看一下
今天的
今天的那个
大家投票
投投票聊聊天吗
来
那AI如果真的很强
其实这个也可以上新闻
AI真的快赢人类
怎么办
好不好
气象源会用预测
但产出还是以人为分析
如果全AI
就不就自己开吐自己了
你在讲没错
对吧
气象会员
气象源
他们气象主播
如果用AI模式
那个不就是代表
不需要他们吗
幸好我们分析师
不会被取代
你知道吗
是
因為人的心理很難用一個預測能力
你看韓國股市現在利多給我跌
你給我看什麼預測
本益比有減少嗎
有增加嗎
不是就是本益比有過
之前那麼高現在才修正
為什麼我們必要這個時候修正
因為公佈了一個
或者其實
你這AI怎麼知道這個事情
比如說我要去杠桿
我韓國的那個金融監督會
然後就是類似台灣的金管會
哇還說我應該要阻止這個杠桿ETF
然後開始韓國股市震盪了
你怎麼知道這會影響股市
是
可是股市很難用AI去預測的
所以股市
所以還是需要我
我最不怕被AI取代了
OK
這跟大家講
全台灣最懂氣象的分析師
好不好
OK嗎
這跟大家講
來來來
A350以前
對對對
我們是做星宇的
星宇還為了我們特地調飛機
我們去打聽一下就知道了
去布拉格
布拉格最近蔡依林不是那個嗎
不是那個
不是在打廣告嗎
每週三班我都看到
有
我們等同半包機的好不好
不過他人很多
大概350人以上
前面的投冷餐 商務餐 金餐
金餐 金餐 豪金餐被我們包了
好 來來來 車遠的
我以為走錯頻道
這這這這
這跟AI有關係 怎麼會走錯頻道咧
來我們看一下 試了投票了沒 還沒投
試了要睡覺嗎
投了
投了 怎麼沒看到
等一下喔 再一次喔
沒有耶 為什麼看不到
看到看到
AI模式離台灣比較遠
一半一半
說實話一半人說
哎呀翻大翻大
這52%啦好不好
AI模式離台灣比較遠
清醒台灣48%
看起來很多人是覺得
算了生命比較重要
我不知道你們有沒有喊什麼除冠意見
我是覺得AI啊
我是覺得這個
這也是個話題
是好像金字日報可以投版
投投投投投投稿啦
這就是個話題啊
這個AI玩一下
到底是AI勝過人還是人勝過AI
是
我這要說
我會說三者之一耶
我會說
我硬要我說
我會說兩者的合併耶
什麼意思你知道嗎
我如果只能選一個原因
我會說傾向於AI
我不要到時候變明天多重播喔
我會變成傾向於怎麼樣
那個AI模式
硬要我說的話
我會說傾向於AI模式
只能選一個嘛
就完全這樣子嘛
那如果要我選
如果是我自己發表言論的話
我會說來看一下
傳統模式在這邊嘛 對不對
AI模式在這邊嘛 對不對
沒錯 在這邊嘛 對不對
我會介入中間
就是也就算用到也是用到一點點北台灣
甚至可能沒用到
但沒像他那個沒像剛才AI模式那麼距離這麼遠對對對對對這樣懂我意思嗎順便到處我最準
看一下喔
這是AI模式嘛對不對
好 那我們畫個圖
來
我的意思是說這是AI模式對不對
我畫這邊
有可能稍微分差一點點這邊
你知道嗎
不會像傳統模式這邊
大概這邊 傳統模式這邊
AI模式在這邊 我就在中間
我覺得有可能
反正我比較請你投AI模式一票
有的話你能想看投資AI股
好不好 好玩是這個東西
好不好
不過講話要不要放假
他一定是依照氣象局
氣象局又因為傳統模式
是
好不好 我覺得這個東西明天可以上新聞
如果誤差很大的話
然後政府又放假的話
然後發現哎呦
明明就沒有離台灣很近
就好玩了
明明就離台灣很遠就好玩了
好不好
AI準的話就泡沫
怎麼會呢
AI準的話代表跟他投資啊
好不好
少到颱風尾 沒錯
希望是AI
但是要做好傳統路線的反台準備
這是沒錯
機會留給準備好人
就像我買特斯拉
我就等他那天
FSD通過的時候我就去開他
我現在連摸都沒摸他
我現在我的包摩產商那邊
叫他 盡量放折一下
好不好 這跟大家講
OK嗎 來來來
哲哲世界掛了 玩有贏了
你要拜託一下 這叫掛了
之前精采有人這樣講
我跟你講一件事情
世界這叫掛了 我跟你講
有本事跟哲哲對坐
我這講一次
環球經會有這種展法
世界先進絕對不會
不要說絕對
99% 因為我們不好意思
我們不能說100%
可是我說99%已經很高了
就像我今天來看一件事情
你給我找一件事情
我不知道剛才那個網友故意的
好不好
剛才把那個網友
不好意思
封鎖
這次不需要酸民來驗證我
好不好
OK嗎
你們也不必說這次
為什麼你要封鎖人家
你每天被人家罵你會封鎖人家
會啊
好不好
OK
我不跟那些人廢話
有本事跟郭忠榮對坐
看誰火
好不好
OK嗎
我只要講一件事情
你去找哪一位分析師
1800人的股票裡面
你看喔
可以今天創新高的
你製造一堆股票現在還在破題
沒錯吧
是
現在一堆股票破棄
你看2327國巨是今天好不能拉起來
可是它是黑K耶
看起來就破底啊
是不是
是不是逃命波呢
啊你去看一堆股票
很弱耶
2308台達店你看起來就破底有沒有看到
台達店走勢耶
各位投資朋友
你告訴我哪一檔股票
拜託你現在打我臉
有價有量
然後還能創新高還能鎖持暫停
這講一次
全台灣哪一檔股票
除了精彩以外
放大放大
哪一檔股票除了精彩以外
有價有量
還能鎖死暫停
這種行情耶
越想越生氣真的是
不要真的不會開話下來
那個表演效果
可是我老實要告訴你
我就是跟人家不一樣
剛才講個颱風天你就忘記我是分析師了是不是
我是分析師全台灣最紅的
188%的男人
忘記了是不是
全台灣唯一百萬粉絲的
你告訴我哪一個分析師
哪一個台灣股需要1800多檔股票
哪一檔股票比精彩還強
一檔都沒有啦
有價有量
今天展停板還是有些展停板股票
但他不是穿新高
就算穿新高也不是有價有量
今天不好意思啦
今天量還比較少一點
就鎖展停的嘛
50億而已啦
至少有價有量吧
我實際還夠我塞牙縫啊
再講一次哪一檔股票有比金財還強
有價有量的
沒有
沒有啦
1800檔
就做這一檔最強的啦
我每次講精彩
之前跌的時候
跟世界一間跌的時候
一樣我照講
不要算子澤
我告訴大家一件事情
子澤喔 抱抱抱不錄啦
我抱抱抱不錄啦
真的 我是跟你講真的
子澤早就財富自有了
我現在只對那種愛我的人珍惜
你知道嗎
所以我愛
我現在還錄的原因是因為很多會員
好不好
啊會員朋友你們不用擔心啦
我只要你們簽多久
基本上我就
我就錄多久
有些要求我簽個好幾年
簽個三四年的會員
是
所以我對那種非會員我現在
尤其是
比較愛抱怨沒有什麼耐心
抱抱抱我看點閱率
就不夠好
我就把它停掉
那我把它停掉是這樣子
因為我覺得這對我流量沒有幫助
我覺得當然還是好幾萬人
那我覺得有議題的時候我再錄
沒有議題我就不要固定週六錄了
好不好 OK嗎
所以我跟你講 只是心境不同
我現在也是一樣
同業那些什麼公集 只是也都不在乎
我告訴大家一個好消息
我是要講一下
因為今天查出來一個消息
來 查出來一個消息
這則是唯一 來
看清楚
這則全台灣唷
唯一法院
應該說檢察官證明
全台灣文藝法院
證交所證明
絕不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
你知道為什麼有時候我講的那個
攻擊我同業
我今天一定要講這個事情
不好意思
我知道我自己不要講那麼久
你們有些人不想聽
去年不是有一個同業嗎
是
一直搞我
我說你這樣搞我
搞到什麼
你自己業績搞差了
你眼睛也變不好
然後那個都做心戰的刀
那次我告訴他他還做輪椅
我不知道是要給法官看的
還是給我看的我不知道
可是我真的覺得滿心疼的
早知如此何必亂出
可是你知道嗎
之前啊 一群一直叫人家檢舉我怎麼樣
你把自己搞得不好要幹嘛
第二件事情
還有什麼自救會啦
自救會他也在現場啊
搞得好像我做什麼壞事才自救會啦
然後告我 一群人要自救會告我
那告我怎麼樣
不好意思了 他們還
那法院啊 檢察官啊
你知道嗎 那些警察還掉
還掉什麼 真希大隊啊
還掉那些我說的
看有沒有交易紀錄
我也沒有出貨給會員
還行文證交所喔
是
行文證交所喔
現在證明了完全沒事
唯一絕不跟主力掛告分析師
喔 告我 我歡迎
因為現在反而還我清白
而且你知道一件事情喔
我本來一直查喔
我後來發現喔
他們告書了
他們知道他們告書了
可是我覺得為什麼沒有
法院為什麼沒傳話我
檢察官為什麼沒傳話我
來 這個你們可以去查
你們去問書記官
確骨
110年度他治1233號
直接簽解啊
什麼叫簽解你知道嗎
這什麼意思
檢察官認為證據不足
很不足的嫌疑不明啊
不做出正式起訴或不起訴處分
就結案什麼意思
我連不起訴都不用給了
你不用來了啦
不起訴處分你還可以什麼在意喔
不是
我連不起訴都沒有
是
不起訴還有法院的網站上面還可以查到喔
你聽懂嗎
查到不起訴書
是
不好意思 我連不起訴都沒有
叫千傑 你不問所有的法院人叫千傑
沒關係 我給你字號啊
你可以去問啊 問書記官檢察官啊
應該都書記官回答你啊
都有記錄
所以法院證明了
我選的匯票也有這麼多練
我這個以後要多講幾次啊
謝謝他們啊
真機不怕我練
我不敢說我是超級聖人
但投資上至少我不會去害你啦
我不敢說我每個紅綠燈我不會闖黃燈
我不敢這樣說啦
我不會闖黃燈可能偶爾不小心闖個黃燈
投資上我覺得清清白白
我說我節目都可以不錄了
沒差我就為你們啦
都替你們早想
可是你看喔 我的心態越正常
有緣沒緣
大家來相會
沒緣就不要相會
我心態越正常
我股票現在有夠強
全台灣現在股票最強就是我啦
那就是我啊
有什麼好講的
精彩喔
我直接整個講你自己看
三三七七十精彩
精彩還不是我最強的股票耶
真的很精彩耶
講個世界應該我氣成這樣子
226你看
真的要敲桌子啊
我很開心啊
喔法院方法證明
全台灣唯一啊
法院啦
證交所證明的
欸那時候還行文證交所喔
是
郭子偶有沒有跟主力配合
不好意思沒有
真的沒有
連起訴都沒有起訴
還不是不起訴
是千結
謝謝
全台灣我有這經歷的只有我啊
你去問所有的學法律什麼叫千結
比不起訴的嫌疑更低
低到幾乎為零
去查我那些股票啊
我就覺得好好笑
他查什麼
查星星啊
是
然後
有點又好笑的生氣
查星星啊
100多塊給你掉70塊
我就混蛋了
那70幾塊
然後拉到現在1000多塊怎麼辦
去查星星
有沒有跟主力配合
來
來來來
我不用配合我都知道主力
我知道大會在想什麼
我不需要我不需要我真的不需要
而且我們選都是有價有量
有基本面的股票來
226塊看一下
精彩有沒有看到
4個展停板
5個展停板
6個展停板
7個展停板
8個展停板
哇好像環球競一樣
9個展停板
10個展停板
精彩我至少加碼4次
我說普通會員啦
我印象中至少加碼4次
有沒有看到
恭喜3374精彩
股價連兩天噴展停
突破再串歷史新高
我們多次買進最高一段
83%的啦
我自己看我拿手上持股的活力氣爆
來看一下
所以我跟你講
不論你是會員或是不是會員
你拜託你有耐心一點好不好
真心不怕我練
那些人聽到那些什麼
不知名報紙
一些分析師可以手揚你
你把股票卡在最低點
是誰的錯
是他們害你啦
他們害你不相信我
你不相信我
你的股票是不是卡在低點
是
你不相信我
你股票卡在低點啊
所以我跟你講一件事
你記得一件事
業績不好的老師
最後業績不好的老師才想要去
或者業績沒有很好老師才能攻擊別人
為什麼
你業績好你會有時間
你會有時間想攻擊別人嗎
沒有
不要騙自己了啦
你績效好會業績不好嗎
不要騙自己啊
你績效很好每天展覽板
怎麼可能業績不好
業績不好老師
相對的基本上績效一定不好
那你就本事把自己績效調起來就好了
敬告各個同業
不要搞嘖嘖
嘖嘖就不會回籍
開心
全台灣唯一法院政要的證明
絕不跟主力掛鉤分析師
我不需要
我連大屋都想什麼的預告
來看一下我節目做精彩
精彩是不是今天展停版沒錯吧
是
今天展停版沒錯吧
全台灣1800檔股票
全台灣1800檔股票裡面
唯一檔有價量
所使展停的就是3370精彩
我最快一倍了
80幾%
那是普通會員而已啊
看一下
看一下我昨天的預告
有我這樣經濟的人真的很屌
用這個字不好意思
經濟日報唯一選股基务保持者
是
是不是
那個全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
全台灣證交所
然後法院認證的
還滿行文趣的
查我那些股票的進出
有沒有人特 怎麼叫出貨
我叫會員買 然後偷偷賣掉
你聽懂嗎
懂
聽懂嗎
然後就叫出貨
為什麼出貨
就接在最高點
那你接在最高點啊
做這種事
我完全不屑
我這種
你們邏輯好一點
有些人邏輯好一點
怎麼會批評我呢
我連1.74億美債
我都卡在那邊
我少賺2億了
偶爾沒怎麼樣啊
我怎麼會為了幾百萬
然後毀掉我投資的一個良心呢
幾千萬我也不屑啊
這件事我幾千萬我也不會改變我想法
幾億我也不會啊
我說事實啊幾億我也不會啊我沒有在乎那些錢啊救護救護車我都捐了是不是 這幾年都捐幾千萬你自己看所以 我跟你講為什麼投資的誠信很重要
有誠信才有暫停板啊 很多傻瓜問我什麼騙
你都相信人家的暫停板 他先騙你啦
那暫停板什麼用 你要先確定人家的暫停板是真的啊
你懂不懂
不是有時候發個解訊就好啦
你怎麼知道什麼等級或怎麼樣的
來看一下我們之前重播
看一下 我連大戶在想什麼都知道
真的是很拽 很屌
來好了
看一下
激怒大戶去吃個大戶
沒錯吧
7月8號 昨天的喔 來
吃個大戶戶
真的啦 我覺得那個大戶如果今天硬拉的是大戶
明天沒有拉起展頂 我看不起他
明天沒有拉起展頂 我看不起他 有沒有
我是預告
是
不管你們有沒有搜尋到
不管你們有沒有聽到聲音
現在可能像聲音
剛才有聲音
剛才應該是一一剛才聽到有聲音的
不重點
一一剛才聽到每聲音其實實際上有聲音
可是現在沒有了
對啊
現在是這邊有聲音
好不重要
明天有沒有拉起暫停我看不及答
你看我預告這個東西
然後繼續看
這邊這麼有GAS敢拉暫停
明天就應該再拉了啦
明天就應該再拉了有沒有看到
聽懂嗎
來
這種走勢是明天應該再拉暫停
我聽懂嗎
這種走勢是明天應該拉暫停
有分寄師敢預告嗎
這種總是明天應該拉閃停
我遮住了 不好意思
我遇到他前面
朋友
請你告訴我
我需要跟準利配合嗎
我能到位在前什麼知道
他昨天那種拉法
今天就拉閃停了
不然你丟臉啦
我是在這樣講 我還開玩笑
可是想想 我說不要激怒人家
是
我怕因為他又不是李維
激怒李維
不好笑是不是
這個人
蠻好笑的
這個人 你確定懂他嗎
激怒李維
好啦 扯一扯遠了
好啦 來 我們看一下
來來
所以我要講的是
你去想看你要採用分音室
我不去吃肉泡
我不去馬肉泡
好不好
OK嗎來看一下
來來
有聲音有聲音
他說有聲音
麥克風有聲音實際上沒有
沒關係
一直有
現在才有啦
好啦
沒有關係沒關係不重要
好不好
反正以後把它搞定就好
我年輕事真的沒有
好大家不用變那個
所以我跟他很小聲
這不知道我們看字幕
我剛才有講過了嗎
是
大戶如果明天沒有拉暫停
就今天精彩
我瞧不起他
我開玩笑的喔
我以後不要吃起他
明天就要拉暫停了啦
有沒有
我一高在前面啦
我必須說話不去買二砲啦
是不是
這跟大家講
昨天這樣精彩大戶有用
我刺激法
激將法
激將法 對 激將法 對不起
今天馬上再拉一根暫停棒
激動者則不要生氣
剛才求好心氣耶
好不好
折太強了有沒有看到
這種反應世界無敵
不要都怪
但他怪醫啊
不能說不能怪醫啊
這就是他要做的事情啊
除非是我的問題
沒關係我們再了解他一下
我們再了解情況一下
來
AI模式主力不想被折看不起
歡迎他
所以我跟你講
法院認證這件事
法院認證的
全台灣絕對
那不代表別人就會跟喔
可是至少我可以證明我是清白
是不是
是
歡迎我
這麼多眼睛看著我
一百多萬隻眼睛看著我
唉
能做壞事嗎
幸好我也不需要做這些壞事
好不好
至少投資的清白
我清清白白啦
好不好 OK
好 來來
唉 這就是你要的分析師啦
喔 我看對商人也是很有創意
什麼事都想
什麼事都想攻擊
喔 扯得很遠
啊 可是做那些幹嘛
很多人 很多人 我想
還是在講30秒
很多人覺得 攻擊別人
好像自己的業績會增加
不會增加多少的啦
好 車遠了
來 我們最後看一下
所有股票是不是很開心
6488環球金
今天環球金要是再暫停的時候
全台灣唯一兩支喔
串心高啊
因為差30塊串心高
全台灣唯一兩支有價有量
而且公善閃停還能串心高股票
不就是環球金
如果今天環球金也串心高
差30塊啦
所以我告訴你世界先進
你不用緊張好不好
那磨的磨的磨嘛
是不是而且你要加個4塊錢好不好
加快5塊錢好不好 OK嗎
看起來就沒那麼嚴重好不好
你們不能鼓勵就要紅海一樣
你們不能鼓勵就不算你們的
你們不能看加鼓勵就沒那麼差你知道嗎
沒加鼓勵看起來要破底的你知道嗎
你們不要不是鼓勵的
給他給我鼓勵好不好
鼓勵不能不算你們的
鼓勵算你們的然後不給我鼓勵
不行
這字幕不要打錯
鼓勵就算你們的不給我鼓勵
沒那那那
欸 你們要想想一件事欸
為什麼全台灣就我的精彩最強
代表基本上所有
我不知道批評人家 我講的是現象
所有分析是大家現在的績效都不太好啦
我這樣績效已經很好了啦
隨隨便便三檔股票展聽班
我不是每天講個幾百檔股票
突然變來變去
你給我股票我變來變去變很快嗎
沒有啊
沒有 我出掉出掉
我好激動
我真的滿
我跟大家講喔
我在禮拜天跑步的時候啊
講小故事喔
我還覺得我沒有以前努力
因為我在想說我停掉爆爆爆
停掉福利社
是否是一種不努力的表現
你知道我會死喔
苛責兩個禮拜
苛責自己兩個禮拜
真的我是這種人
然後我覺得我現在連跑步喔
好像都提不起勁
怎麼跑步我都不敢用力跑
好像很累
然後那天我就逼自己用力跑
然後我覺得好累
怎麼奇怪
怎麼跑個五分數六分數而已喔
我就快累死了
我好累喔
很累喔
然後我在河堤上睡著
你不知道跑步很累的時候會直接睡著
你不用問很多人
真的運動很累的時候
你當下就可以睡著了
就昏迷不行
不要再昏迷不行
就會睡著 真的會睡著
河堤旁邊睡著
然後呢
我就覺得
怎麼會體力變那麼差
怎麼我沒有近百分之百的力量
後來發現我錯了
隔天我開始狂咳嗽
我就問Gemma
他說你開始發炎了
我這邊就拉扯到了
我不是剛做肺結結手術
我想說已經三個多月了
可以開始用力了吧
就是用力的吧
很多人說一個月就可以運動了
結果沒有
那個深處還是有點發炎
還是有點拉扯到痛
所以後來發現我以為我沒有人盡力
其實我只是從200%的折折
大概變成150% 120%的折折
還是很努力
只是我選擇哪邊發力 選擇哪邊發力
我不會變200%
因為這樣可能早死
我還是要跟大家
我想跟大家天長地久
所以有些我覺得沒那麼喜歡的
我覺得有點累的
對我來說CP值不高
對我啦
像比如說福利社對某人來說CP值還是很高
對我來說CP值不高
因為我為什麼福利社對我來說CP值不高
為什麼不錄
因為它花非常多時間
而且我寧願把那時間抽出來
我一對一
所有的業務 所有的同仁
分析師
稍微跟他們講這些重點
他們業績會變扎很多
所以就是跟大家講這些東西
扯遠的我
我永遠是100
至少是100%
120%的則子
你們不用擔心
好不好
選他太低
沒有啦 我選他還好
好不好
明天還有誰暫停
集中在直播就好
看哲哲直播比較有趣
謝謝大家
來來
呼籲哲哲
120%
媽啊
120% 真的
太真實了
納科有沒有機會穿新高
納科真的很強
一半一半耶
我說老實話
我對納科就這樣子
就有時候
不好意思 我講完實在話
有時候就像
比如說我管理整個團隊而已
管理團隊是怎麼樣
你好我就加強你
你不好我就給高欣嘛
你不好做不到我要求
不好意思我們有緣再見
反正只要高欣放在這邊
你符合就進來
你不想做我也沒辦法
我就送你走
或者沒達到要求送你走
所以我同樣的我對南亞科
現在就是管理團隊的感覺
記得一句話
我現在對南亞科管理團隊的感覺
看技術線型
沒有跌破這邊
我就按命不動
有跌破這邊可能會有行動
沒有跌破我就等他
這樣怎麼到
如果洗了再上去呢
那我不管他 我這邊出就出嘛
我可以以後追 我也可以不追
可是這邊出 我怎麼樣也是賺個六七十%可不可以
我怎麼樣也是賺個七十%可不可以
可以
可以嘛
這就是低成本的好處
你知道為什麼我現在會有那麼多嗎
除了本來粉絲就多基礎大以外
基礎多以外
最主要是什麼
最主要是因為我現在的股票績效很好
我績效很好的原因是因為我都選低基礎的股票
我都選第一期期的我不要
像很多人都緊張啊
台灣股市會不會怎麼樣
會不會怎麼樣
你知道嗎
我跟人家不用擔心
記住我名言
來
來我們跟你插賭要不要
有沒有人跟我插賭
跟我賭一下
台股沙尾盤對不對
這本來是標題啦
後來想說颱風的標題比較爽動
台股沙尾盤但遲早10萬點
有沒有人跟我賭
有沒有人跟我賭吧
反正你比較愛喊嘛
有那6萬點 7萬點 10萬點
如果是10萬點
我管你今天是4萬5還是4萬點
你幹嘛理他
如果是10萬點
那現在回到4萬點
或跌破4萬點
你是要加碼還是要賣掉
我知道你想說你當股神
我都很難預測了
我這個一堆人稱我股神的
我那時候不是說
那個美一戰爭要跌4000點到6000點嗎
雖然跌4000點
但沒跌6000點
害我沒加碼到最低點
是
所以你不是股神
你為什麼要抓最低賣最高
你不是股神 為什麼你不學我一樣
當股市渣男
採取人家人生中 股票中最精華的一段
於頭於尾送給別人啊
送給別人家很開心的 謝謝你
是不是你聽得懂我還說什麼吧
懂
所以我告訴你不要去猜啦
不要猜 真的假的 十萬點記得
真的真的 我跟你講真的
就是我跟你講因為真的
因為不是我跟你講 我不是像你嘛
因為不是每個人數學敏感度像我那麼厲害
我們給你一個東西好不好
我們算一個東西好不好
我們算個台股喔 來來來
台股喔
前幾年喔
來 2025年就好了
你們記得 2025年
2025年是不是
2025年記不記得
去年事情沒錯吧
是
去年事情看台股有沒有周限來看
不好意思喔
這樣
我們要抽些來看
去年怎麼樣
17306點沒錯吧
對不對
沒錯
這17000嘛對不對
對
17306然後跟48000沒錯吧
你看這邊就好了
看不到嗎
沒關係
一幫我放大一下
真的放大嗎
是17000對不對
沒錯吧
是
這是
你記不記得那時候的股災
去年的時候什麼時候
這去年很誇張耶
感覺要過好幾年一樣
為什麼就是去年都這樣
真的是去年而已喔
記不記得去年那時候不是那個
那個什麼
那個關稅嗎
川普的關稅協定有沒有
是
關稅之戰
關稅之亂
來喔
然後你來看一下
現在放大放大
今年最高點是48000
看17000嘛對不對
好 我們除一下喔
17000點
這點數應該沒錯
事長幫我查一下
24000 17000
沒錯
17306跟48000
因為我看一看
我會覺得很扯
算是
17306幫我記一下
好
我們用48000就好了
我扯遠了
我先問你問題
不好意思
這邊17000漲到48000比較難
還是48000漲到10000點比較難
感覺好像差不多差了3萬點沒有這也是喔來來來 我們用這個裝置
Lily也在想不知道真的演還是假的演
沒有關係
演的效果不錯
對不對
到48000
沒關係不用了不用放大
跟48000
到10萬
不好意思用簡體字
請問哪個比較難
17000到18000比較難
48000到10萬
不好意思我是用畫圖的所以很醜
我告訴你哪個比較難好不好
這個難多了
因為這個只是翻一倍而已
這翻好幾倍
懂不懂
懂了
懂了沒
懂了齁
來再給你講
出17000
17306啦差不多啦
長了2.8倍
是不是沒錯吧
是
2.8倍
長了180%
扣要1的話180%
然後呢
10萬點
除以多少
4萬8
除以4萬8
有沒有看到
兩倍多而已啊
是不是
一個2.8倍
一個2倍
2.1倍
所以
那你的最顯示是喔
哪個最顯示是喔
我才一年多的時間就漲了
兩倍
漲到1.8倍
从17000就对
漲到48000
一年的时间没错吧
是
4月早到今年6月
一年时间就漲到48000
为什么你纽约觉得台湾股市
10万点难
至少10万点
要喊大家一起来
而且我有信心
只要我长命百岁
基本上99.99999999
一定到
有沒有跟我賭
你錢多可以跟我賭啊
沒有自信哦
所以我要告訴大家
就是來
所以台灣股是遲早的
這也代表一件事
錢越來越薄
哇很多人聽我的話
這幾年台灣股子賺翻了
賺50%賺一倍
他們現在都覺得
投資產好緊張哦
不用緊張
不用怕
好不好
OK嗎
不用怕
請問一下中美金
可以振作一點嗎
不用怕
環球金拉上去中美金遲早
可是我跟你講
那環球金比較標還是中美金
不好意思
理論上還是什麼
中美金會比較標
理論上會環球金比較標
人家說中美金正做一點
我講好像是越間跌
大哥 今天台灣股市跌
中美金真的很強
你看
玩友們多貪心
還是會員們多貪心
真的
中美金的走勢
你說正做一點
那也難怪世界先進
你要罵我
事件先進我很多會議還是賺錢的
只是有些人逢高加碼
逢高進場
OK嗎
再講一次
我們的績效都實實在在
全台灣買一個人有像精彩一樣
可以在今天暫停鎖時
然後創新高
創立新高
然後有價有量
不一定要創新高
創新高就好
暫停創新高
然後有價有量
哪一檔有贏他
沒有就聽我的建議嘛
台灣股市至少遲早10萬點了
所以你在想是拉回做多
為什麼很多人現在績效不好
因為沒選到金財這種股票
沒選到環球金啊
2009、81A把金財賣到奇長點
你們都知道
那時候有人說
你搖瓷吉姆跟你對坐
我說你不要這樣講
我們要跟他比較
他也不需要跟我比較
好不好
他壓力很大
我壓力很大
但我們不同性質
OK嗎
他要常常被人家檢視
但不用露臉
但我要每天露臉被人家檢視
這樣懂不懂
就拖光光給你們看
今天外資賣470幾億
那不重要
韓國股市不要跌就好
OK嗎
OK
來來
中美金沒什麼漲
你看沒什麼漲
2%就沒什麼漲
請退出的頻道
OK
來來
哲哥都不說中美金
這種態度我不喜歡
沒有欠各位
之前也是
我跟網紅最大的差別
有些 尤其不是財經界的
是
你知道什麼
我不需要各位同情我
你也不會同情我
當我不準的時候
我也不需要拜託你
為什麼
當我暫停股票一堆的時候
你就會自己來看我
不論我轉或不轉
有本事跟我對坐
我績效不是最好
那誰是績效最好
哎呀 不要用刺刺刺刺刺的
好不好
OK嗎
來
今天才暫停 繁圈世界
是不是有機會來了
好 來
這種問法我就可以接受
6196凡圈
當然有機會
今天那個萬潤
現在幾分
萬潤
萬潤今天拉
萬潤以前
我記得萬潤
我其實被人家罵得要死
也是跌不到100塊
被人家罵得要死
那時候甘主持福利社
還2021、2022年的事情
忘記了
給你看
用月線
2020年的時候
不到100塊
50塊而已
吃不到
你看吃不到
是不是
50块而已
有没有看到
2023年也不到
2023年也不到100块
50块有没有看到
现在1000块
天哪
这一堆股票
常常变家骂
桌子涨上去
这点是
台湾股市迟少10万点
你在在乎那1000点的回答要干什么
来 这点是
傻瓜财阀前半银行
跟我一起念
傻瓜
来 一起念
等一下 重来
我們一起聊好不好
傻瓜才
傻瓜
跟上我 跟上我
傻瓜才把錢放在銀行
真的 你傻了
你可以放部分
你把他
你把他零零五零
你那時候哲哲我不想要那麼刺激的精彩
那可以啊
我們交朋友
就把他放台灣50
再保守一點
一半台灣50
然後一半怎樣
然後一半那個納斯達克的ETF
你一一一二
送我個餅乾
我就跟他講那麼多好話
那我不業配
那是我不業配
不拿錢的
就是買那種保守的ETF
你十年後會愛上我
真的把錢發銀行
100萬
1萬塊利息
你好厲害
這就是數學不好
我要前提一下
這數學不好
考試考100分
但實際上數學不好
你的錢被銅膨給吃掉
看起來100萬變102萬
你的定存利息
其實以上你的購買力道只有98萬而已
類似這樣子
傻瓜在把錢放銀行
知道嗎
我要幫你們做很多事情
好不好
假話同時台紙企業盤小展兩百點
真的很小展
明天開市比較好啦
好不好
明天我認為不會放假啦
OK
我把有點私心啊
兩個私心
第一個
我先進AI模式
第二個
就算是傳統模式
明天放假機率也很高
第三個
我想工作
我愛工作
雖然減少工作量
但我愛工作
所以抱抱抱
從定期變成不定期
停了以後
你們更珍惜者摺
看一次少一次
我沒可以開玩笑
只是現在做工作是做開心的
不要拿者摺不開心
知道嗎
不然少看者摺
除非你是別人派來的
要壓起來
來
來 現在幾分了
47啦 好啦
來
中美金2022年有240元過
現在目前真的算低級型
你看折的厲害就是可以買低基金股票
本來就是中美金有240元
為什麼我現在不斷240元
為什麼不能算
2022年台灣股市1萬7耶
1萬2 最低1萬2啦
所以中美金是1萬2
不要說1萬2誇張嘛
那是那時候嘛
那他支2萬點的中美金啊
沒有錯啊
OK嗎
折折比很多投信買入環球金
環球金更不用講
來來看一下
最後錯比一下
精彩83%沒錯吧
剛才精彩有幾個等領版
你自己看喔
來我們看喔
掌握幾個
一個等領版
兩個等領版
三個等領版
四個等領版
五個等領版
六個等領版
七個等領版
八個等領版
九個等領版
十個等領版
在這過程中
基本上我沒有記錯的話
我就是一直在加碼
除非會有特殊需求
不然我就是加碼
加碼加碼加碼就好
十個掌領版
看到精彩83%
我最高的贏大多
83%我持續考
他手上是活力虛報
竟然討厭的是
我六月初加碼後
我就沒再加碼
為什麼 一直在漲啊
是
環球金暫停
暫停 暫停 暫停
我巴不得拉回
你們在踏什麼
股票拉回要開心啊
都要十萬點了
八個暫停
我問你啊
730元我們買進
跌停板喔 買進喔
叫你跌停板買進
而且你要注意喔
要先全程才能買
想請你家庭的營業員
趕快買
是少數從高檔回檔
高點回彈30%的極油股
我們看到
而且即將恢復正常交易
你們看到每次恢復正常交易
就噴出去展停有沒有
是
他是少數的
不是那跌停就展停的
我不要
呵呵呵
呃
他不是那種小型股喔
他是全職大股喔
他是三櫃指數前五大喔
除了新委員掛跌停
730元買進
我已經持有黃小金的老會員
也可以試單的加碼
什麼叫加碼
買第一次嗎
不是啦
買好幾次了
怎麼知道
買第二次以上
黃小金
10個人沒滿
12個人沒滿
9%
這場
500元長現在
我已經獲利145%了啦
好
那個聲音變什麼
不要音啊
最高已經獲利145%
我自己剛拿1025獲利188
你告訴我誰不要比我強
我照疊我也照講啊
那個中美金剛才2%對他們抱怨
你們是怎樣
好啦沒有關係啦
歡迎比較啦
比一比你還是覺得我比較好啦
是不是
就是去比啊
比啊 比勒
比勒
要比在這邊比啊
好啦 開玩笑 冷笑話
OK嗎
群聯就不講了
群聯本人就要噴出去的
群聯我剛才遲早也要噴出去的
好不好
那沒關係
等他EPS出來你們就知道了
好不好 群聯
日線用日線
OK嗎 understand
然後什麼股票
凡宣有覺得啦
凡宣金你看連發科
人發科又沒有4000元了
你知道
我一開始的時候4000元
我把它賣掉
你相信他1萬元了
我跟你講有些人都害你啦
好不好
我不要講誰啦
不要講那些外資啦
好不好
有點聳動
所以不論對我做結束了
現在幾班了
50要結束了
趕快來啦
納科分析師在一堆股票展停板
我還沒有講人亞科咧
笑死人咧
納科展停還沒有秀咧
納科賺到70還50
我想我真的很忙
我不想講的啦好不好
納科你看一個兩個
納科
賺了82%
82啦
全部都八幾了
不然100%啦
納科暫停
環球金暫停
一堆股票暫停
你告訴我
納科也暫停
來來來
然後勒
金財也暫停
來來來
6488環球金暫停
你以為他對股票一樣
都暫停
誰又比我強啦
歡迎來一下
行 08066885
加我LINE私訊我
全台灣法院認證
不好意思啊
證教所認證
我不跟手機配合
重點是現在誰計較比我好
去下輪看你要怎樣分析
我下一段標股
我跟我一起來賺大錢
謝謝各位
谢谢大家